what role do women play in relationship
to man well first they make themselves
conscious let's not ever forget about
that because I would say the primary
role that women have in relationship to
men is to make them self conscious and
men don't precisely like that there's
nothing that will make a man more
self-conscious than being rejected and
why because why is he rejected well
obviously mother nature in the guise of
that particular woman has said you're
not so bad for a friend but there's no
reason that your genetic material should
propagate itself into the future right
well and it's not like men are exactly
happy about being made but made
self-conscious by women right it's a
major source of continual tension
between men and women and it's no wonder
but it's also the case and this is
something really cool and interesting to
know you know we divulge dive divulge
guy whatever that's it diverged we
diverged from the common ancestor
between us and chimpanzees about 6
million years ago here's why at least in
part chimpanzee females are non
discriminant mater's they'll mate with
any male when they go into heat which
human females don't when they go into
heat then any male is allowed access now
the dominant males chase the subordinate
males away and so the dominant males are
more likely to leave offspring but it's
not because of the female choice it's
not the case with human beings human
females engage in hypergamy and
hypergamy is the tend this is also to
cross culturally and it's also quite
it's just as extensive in Scandinavia
not quite there's a bit of attenuation
but not much
women mate across and up dominance
hierarchies man-made across and down ok
when that has to be the case because if
obviously it has to work that way if one
goes up the other has to go down the
socio-economic status of a woman is
almost determines almost zero of her
attractiveness towards a man whereas the
socio-economic status of a man is a
major determinant of his attractiveness
towards a woman and it isn't as wealth
either because that's being tested it's
his capacity to generate and be
productive and to share because that
beats the hell out of wealth wealth can
disappear right but the capacity to be
productive
sher that's that's a much more important
element and why not be chosen on the
basis of that especially because women
have to have infants and infants make
the women dependent and the woman is
just looking logically rationally and
from an evolutionary perspective for
someone who's useful enough to give a
tool and a hat
so women make intense demands on men and
it's no wonder but the thing is is that
because women engaged in hypergamy at
least in part we diverged quite rapidly
from chimpanzees because the selection
pressure that women placed on men
developed the entire species now there's
two things that happened as far as I
could tell the men competed for
confidence let's say so the male
hierarchy is a mechanism that pushes the
best man to the top virtually by
definition and then that's that's the
effect of that is multiplied by the fact
that women who are pergamus appeal from
the top and so that the male's who are
the most competent are much more likely
to leave offspring and that seemed to be
what drove our cortical expansion for
example which happened very very rapidly
over the course of evolutionary time